with a vote and a debate t tip the
transatlantic trade deal had top billing
in Strasbourg but his big premiere bit
the dust new your information button
down office we are hurt the mountains
achievements I'm [ __ ] by Zeta we are
not voting today q chaos in the chamber
please stand up let alone a sauce pizza
but was this democracy in motion amongst
all the commotion were politicians
running scared of course I'm not totally
satisfied with the development but was a
real danger to ever fail and therefore I
think the decision by the president was
right late on Tuesday President Martin
Schulz decided to send the report back
to the trade committee canceling the
vote Sita palomo chiapoe de la democracy
pastilla porque la democracy vomiting
cause the opposite haunted but those in
favor seeing TT progress was simple
baffled the greens are very much pushing
to socialist saw today the green
chairman Rebecca arms she got applause
from her group from the greens and then
from the right populists and from the
left populist and for the Liberals the
disorder showed one thing the division
within the socialist group the chairman
of the trade committee himself who
started to amend the text that we had
agreed with him personally as the
reporter kena me peas find a way out for
the Parliament and what about private
arbitration under t tip the investor
state dispute mechanism oh I SDS
privatized ears and British was dead so
it would seem more battles are yet to
come
right